Hey everybody, welcome
back to Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and it's great
that all of you are there and ready
to watch my second video on this channel.
I'm still super excited
to have done this at all
and be able now to share
my experience with you,
my experiences from my background
in business and management.
So I thought long and
hard about what could be
a good topic for this video,
and I think one thing that many, many,
many new joiners in business struggle with
is behavior in meetings.
And what do I mean that?
Well, you can imagine most corporations,
we have many, many meetings every day.
You probably meet with your team lead,
then with other colleagues
from other departments,
you sit together to discuss topics
and make advancements in the projects
that you're pursuing and
to basically collect input
from other people you're working with.
And recently, a more junior colleague
at my workplace approached me
and asked me about
specifically this topic.
He told me, Heinrich, I'm
sitting in these meetings,
very often I do not
know what really to say.
Is it the right thing for
me as a junior colleague
to say anything at all?
Should I just be there,
listen to the others?
What is my role, what am I expected to do
as a junior colleague in these meetings?
And I could just very
much relate with that.
I clearly remember when I
was a rookie in consulting
and I was sitting in these first meetings
with some senior clients.
I felt highly intimidated.
You're very often not sitting there alone
but then there is your project lead,
your engagement manager,
there is a partner
from your consulting firm there,
full care leader, might
also be a junior partner
and then a whole bunch of clients.
And there was, of course, me as well,
Heinrich, a junior consultant,
new on the team, a rookie,
and I just didn't have
a clue what to do, okay?
And I think this is
just the normal reaction
that many people have when they are facing
these kinds of situations.
So reflecting on that
experience and now looking back,
I think there are three tips that I would
like to share with you, what
you as a junior colleague
actually can do to have
a positive contribution
to the meeting and also to
be perceived a professional.
The first tip I'd like to give you
is to really clarify with your
team lead what your role is.
Go to him and ask him, okay,
we're having this meeting,
I see that I'm part of
the list of participants,
what do you expect me to do?
What is your role?
What shall I do, right?
And one role could be
that you will moderate,
you will lead through the meetings,
you will lead through the agenda,
you will call up the different topics,
make sure that the time is kept
that you are covering
all the topics you want
to discuss in the meeting.
Make sure that you get the contributions
from everybody in the
room and really step up
by just doing a moderation kind of work.
This could be one role, but frequently
this role is more for the more
senior people in the room,
usually the organizer, the person who has
invited to the meeting,
he will usually like
to take charge of the meeting
and be able to do exactly this
and just moderate the whole conversation.
So what can you do?
And my second tip actually would be
that you can be the number guy, right?
That you can be the guy who knows
all the facts and figures about the topics
that you are discussing in the room.
And this can relate to many, many things.
So imagine you're in a sales meeting
and they're discussing how are
the different clients going.
Maybe you're a key account manager
and talking about all these things
and suddenly a question
pops up, for instance,
what revenue did we did
last year in Asia Pacific
or North America or in Europe
with this client, right?
Or what is the revenue
of this country entity
or this local entity, what
are these people doing?
And so on.
And frequently these kinds of questions
are not directly being
answered by people in the room.
People don't know the numbers by heart,
maybe even though they should,
but not everybody does.
And then basically everybody's
like, okay, let's move on.
And here you can be the
guy who just in advance
prepares all these numbers,
has numbers like that at hand
and then can just read them out.
And this is something that
you as a junior colleague
can do because very often
you're sitting on the data,
you're doing the data analysis,
are working in Excel, are
crunching the numbers.
So you are at the source
of all of these things.
And make use of that, this
is a power that you have
that then many people
don't have and don't do
because they're just further
away from the numbers,
not caring that much as you can care.
So make use of that advantage
that you have there.
And this goes further than just
having the numbers at hand,
often there are questions
which you will not be able
to answer right away
and also you cannot have
all the information out there available,
prepared in advance before the meeting,
but you can be the one
who looks it up, right?
Does the question come up,
search for it, look into your systems,
look into your information systems,
just pull the data, get it out,
present it to the rest of the team
because this is then really a value
that you can add to the conversation
by adding data and then being able
to directly pick up the discussion
where this question was being asked
instead of somebody who needs to go back
and then maybe later he can contribute
or distribute the
information to the group.
My third tip would be to always
push for clear next steps
and implications that
come out of the meeting.
We all have been in these meetings
where after hours and hours of discussion
actually nothing is really
clear, nothing has been decided.
It feels like a complete
waste of time to everybody.
So what can you as a junior colleague do
in order to improve that
experience for everybody?
Well, first thing is clarify
what the objective is.
Before you even walk into the meeting,
talk to your team lead, talk
to the meeting organizer
if that is feasible and ask him,
what do we actually want
to take out of the meeting?
And if you feel that
especially towards the end
there is no clear
objective, no clear result
towards that goal that
you wanted to achieve,
make sure that actions
are being taken, right?
Sit together and really
ask each in the room,
okay, what are the things
now that we want to do?
What are the next steps?
Maybe walk up front, go to a flip chart,
write it down what the next steps are
that are supposed to come out of there.
Ask the very simple question,
who was supposed to do what,
until when, and really make
sure that this is clear
and everybody is on
the same page for that.
Because this is just the basics
that just need to be there after a meeting
for it to having had any value at all.
If this is not there, it was just a waste
of time for everybody.
And if other colleagues
do not understand this
or do not see this in
the moment but you do,
then for the sake of everybody,
step up and make sure that these things
are being clarified and done.
Of course, here you need to be
careful for office politics.
Depending on the situation that you're in,
it might be that this
might seem inappropriate
to do as a junior colleague,
so here always also ask your team lead
or other colleagues for feedback
or maybe in the very beginning observe
how other people are
behaving just to make sure
that you do not break with the
kind of more implicit rules
of the organizations, how different people
are supposed to behave,
especially based on tenure
and just what the expectations
of the other people are
to not be basically seen as
an idiot by the colleagues
or just being seen as rude.
This, of course, you should avoid.
So yeah, I think three neat
tips that are really crucial
and important for you to be successful
in meetings as a junior colleague.
First, clarify your role beforehand.
Second, in the meeting, if
there is not another role
that you are assigned
to, be the number guy,
be sure that you inform and distribute
and disseminate all
information that is there
and all the information
that has been asked for
in the meeting.
And third, for the sake
of everybody involved,
make sure that the meeting has a result.
If you do this, I trust
you will be perceived
as a colleague who really
adds value to the meeting.
And I trust this is the experience
that you will make as well.
So keep learning, thank you
for looking at this channel.
Please subscribe if you
haven't done that so far.
This would really mean a lot to me
as somebody who just
starts out with a channel
to see that you are actually enjoying it
and you are ready and only waiting
for new videos so that I will.